.
>> Tucker: APPRECIATE YOUR
COMING ON TONIGHT, THANK YOU.
OBVIOUSLY TWITTER DOESN'T EXIST
SO WE CAN SHARE OPINIONS WITH
ONE ANOTHER.
IT EXISTS TO SILENCE ANYONE WHO
CHALLENGES THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THE OLIGARCHS
IN SILICON VALLEY WHO SUPPORT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND TO
THAT END, THEY CENSOR THE
FOREIGN PRESIDENT, CHARLIE KIRK,
THE SHOW.
LAST NIGHT TWITTER SUSPENDED A
VERY POPULAR ACCOUNT CALLED
LIVES OF TICK-TOCK.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY AN ACCOUNT THAT
FINDS VIDEO OF LIBERALS TALKING
BUT THEMSELVES AND THEIR OWN
BELIEFS AND POSTS IT.
IT WAS OF COURSE TARGETED
BECAUSE ONCE YOU SEE WHAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, THEY
DISCREDIT THEMSELVES AND HORRIFY
NORMAL PEOPLE.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE FOOTAGE.
>> I WANT TO TALK TO THE KIDS.
SOMETIMES HUMAN BEINGS ARE MORE
THAN BOY OR GIRL.
SOMETIMES WE ARE SOMETHING ELSE
SOMETIMES WE ARE BOTH.
SOMETIMES WE KIND OF FLOAT IN
BETWEEN.
>> MOSTLY I FEEL FEMININE OR
NONBINARY.
TODAY I'M FEELING RELIEF THEM
AND CATLIKE AS WELL.
>> SHOULDN'T HAVE TO HIDE OR LIE
OR BE EMBARRASSED ABOUT A
NATURAL FUNCTION MY BODY DOES,
SO ALL THAT TO SAY, I AM ON MY
PERIOD.
YOU HEARD ME.
HAVING A PERIOD FOR A FIRST TIME
IN SIX YEARS, AND NOT JUST ANY
PERIOD, THE PERIOD FROM HELL.
>> IDENTIFY AS A THREAT,
NIGHTMARE, AND A GODDESS, SO
PLEASE BOW DOWN TO ME.
I DO NOT BELIEVE IN GOD, I DON'T
WORSHIP THE DEVIL BUT I AM A
SATANIST, WHICH MEANS I AM MY
OWN GOD AND I WORSHIP MYSELF.
>> Tucker: SO FOR THE CRIME OF
LETTING LIBERALS TALK ABOUT
THEMSELVES AND SHOWING PEOPLE
WHAT THEY ACTUALLY THINK, MEDIA
MATTERS DID A HIT PIECE,
DESCRIBED IT AS HATE AND TWITTER
DUTIFULLY PULLED OFF THE
PLATFORM.
THAT'S EXACTLY HOW THAT SYSTEM
WORKS.
SO THE CREATOR OF IT REMAINS
ANONYMOUS.
WHY?
BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY
WHERE YOU CAN'T EVEN SAY WHAT
YOU THINK WITHOUT THREATS OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST YOU IF YOU'RE
NOT ON THE LEFT.
BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO TALK TO THAT
PERSON OVER THE PHONE, WHICH WE
ARE DOING NOW.
THE CREATOR JOINS US ON THE
LINE.
DON'T KNOW YOUR NAME, GLAD
YOU'RE ON.
SO YOU WERE PULLED OFF TWITTER
AFTER YOU WERE ATTACKED BY MEDIA
MATTERS FOR DISSEMINATING HATE.
WERE YOU SURPRISED BY THIS?
>> EXACTLY.
NO, I WAS NOT SURPRISED AT ALL.
DEFTLY FELT LIKE A VERY
ORGANIZED ATTACKED BY THE LEFT
TO GET ME SUSPENDED.
>> Tucker: SO HOW BIG -- THIS
IS NOT THE FIRST PLATFORM FROM
WHICH IS BEEN SUSPENDED FOR
HOLDING UP LIBERALS IN THEIR OWN
VOICE TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
WHERE ELSE HAVE YOU BEEN KICKED
OFF?
>> I HAVE BEEN KICKED OFF OF
TIKTOK AND MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS
ON INSTAGRAM.
>> Tucker: IT'S JUST
REMARKABLE TO ME IN A COUNTRY
LIKE OURS THAT YOU FEEL THE NEED
TO REMAIN ANONYMOUS.
TELL US WHY YOU'RE NOT GIVING US
YOUR NAME TONIGHT.
>> WELL, I'VE GOTTEN A FEW DEATH
THREATS.
I GET A TON OF HATE MAIL AND THE
LAST HAS BEEN SHOWING RECENTLY
HOW THEY WOULD TREAT PEOPLE WHO
DISAGREE WITH THEM.
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE I REPORTED IT
AND THE PEOPLE, THEY STILL HAVE
THEIR ACCOUNTS ON TWITTER.
YOU CAN THREATEN VIOLENCE BUT
YOU CAN'T PLAY VIDEO OF A
LEFTIST IS SAYING.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
SO YOUR OPINIONS ARE VIOLENCE,
THEY ARE VIOLENCE PROTECTED
SPEECH.
YOU SEE HOW THAT WORKS.
ANCHOR SO MUCH FOR YOUR BRAVERY,
AND AGAIN, I JUST CAN'T
OVERSTATE, YOU'RE NOT EVEN
GIVING THEIR OPINIONS
NECESSARILY, YOU ARE JUST
HOLDING UP THEIR OPINIONS FOR
THE COUNTRY TO SEE AND FOR
REVEALING THEM IN THEIR NATURAL
HABITAT.
YOU'RE ON THE RUN.